pour vous changer on vous a préparé un
top 30 des vidéos les plus marrantes
avec les enfants bien sûr on va réagir
dessus vous allez voir il ya un jeu que
les enfants font tous pendant le
confinement c'est le jeu de la confiance
ça consiste à se laisser tomber dans les
bras d'un autre
hélas le gamin le pauvre n'a pas tout
pigé regarde tous
on va vous montrer un petit jeu qu'on a
des 100 internet est bien sympa à faire
en famille donc est ce que quelqu'un a
essayé alors c'est un jeu pour
travailler la confiance en soi
d'accord avoir confiance aux autres aux
autres parents donc je met les mains sur
les épaules tu vas bien faire mais tes
yeux ok et a3 tu vas te laisser tomber
ok il faudrait qu'ils confiance en nous
ok elle entre en classe
donc même si tu veux c'est à faire
confiance tu peux même sauté pieds des
jambes ça va 1 2 3 le pauvre y est ça va
je lui au téléphone il va bien léché
tout va bien mais c'est vrai que est moi
moi lalalala fait un truc je ferai
jamais en bas conditions nous fait-il
qui fait du roller du roller moi je
kiffe comme du relais non je vous dis
aussi du patin à glace j'adore ça massi
c'est une championne de pâtes à glacer
et quel clip de faire du roller quand
est ado mais quand tu fais ça dans une
pente c'est pas terrible regarde
[Musique]
c'est un truc que je faisais moi quand
j'étais petit ça exactement pareil dans
les parkings sur vous l'avez tous fait
oui oui maxime aussi terrible c'était
vous imaginez ça vous fait du patin à
roulettes vous bien sur ses patins à
roulettes patin à glace castaldi aussi
je crois qu'il est très bon teint c'est
tout ça très très bon patin droit
traîtresse et parce que ma des vrais
vous parlez moi monsieur un avis du
hockey nantes a juste dit moquette a
failli jamais fait du hockey
apparemment j'ai un enfant caché
physiquement se ressemblent pas mais on
adore les mêmes choses
regardez on est pareil c'est sûr c'est
mon fils quatre essais sur elsa est
énorme le petit lot petit chez le fils
de gérard depardieu mais que des coups
de boule tue c'est une bible génial a
réalisé c'est génial mathieu mathieu est
ce qu'il y ait envie d'avoir un enfant
toi c'est une question j'ai envie de te
poser depuis longtemps dit la vérité et
ben aujourd'hui oui avant non pas du
tout aujourd'hui oui après on va être
très honnête il faut un trouver la
personne vaut moins attendu un an de
voir si on s'entend bien
2 il faut adopter c'est très compliqué
pour la lancée de gpa ça prend un an
encore un an pour la voir bref j'aurais
50 ans quand je l'aurai j'ai un doute
mais je pense que je pourrai encore
donné de trois ans après c'est mort mais
aujourd'hui j'adorerais
aujourd'hui je regarde benjamins i là il
est magnifique il va avoir un enfant
bientôt
c'est pendant cinq mois maintenant on
sera là bas alors si on veut avoir
annoncé dans 5 septembre si on veut voir
des enfants partir en vrille faut soit
faire des émissions de l'école des fans
il ya un gosse qui balancent carrément
que ses parents sont alcooliques
cette image est mythique j'ai pas si
vous l'avez vu ça c'est exceptionnel ce
que les enfants ils balancent tout ils
disent toute la vérité à regarder
mon père vit candidats y aura bien
besoin
[Applaudissements]
oui sans tes parents bonjour monsieur
l'électricien et une moustache dit dans
la bande moustache ça j'ai vu comment
c'est son petit nom aux gens si le lien
n'est pas pas commencé son bilan
jean-paul il a une bonne bouille
jean-paul il boit de l'eau du vin j'en
étais sûr c'est un copain à moi combien
il boit par jour maman voix du vin peut
lire les exceptionnels mais ça c'est des
moments mitigé c'est que les enfants ils
balancent tout un sur les parents moi je
me rappelle que j'avais par les offices
de casta ils m'ont dit il va pas papeete
beaucoup à la maison aussi de magie
comme maxime guennic est un grand
magicien et la gamine qui a fait un tour
de route mais vraiment douce regarder
[Musique]
virginia tous mes enfants justement là
on a le fils de claude jamin on a le
fils de benjamin castaldi regarder on a
retrouvé même des vidéos de benjamin
castaldi quand il était au fond
regardez comme ils étaient mignons
petits regarde
[Musique]
tu bois bon ben ça fait du bien d'enfin
images de toits spécifique merci
beaucoup
la prochaine au numéro 24
elle est lunaire c'est un enfant prenez
un enfant un aquarium et vous savez que
ça va rigoler regarde c'est un très bon
père je rentrais sahim au risque ainsi
tout à fait comme ça sert à rien et vous
appelle votre père avant d'arriver à la
maison quand il travaille et je me
rappelle moi quand je recevais mon
bulletin
mon père appelé ma mère avant il disait
passe-moi syrie est une protéine dit
écoute moi même je vais rentrer je vais
t ce quinté je l'étais ce quinté est ce
qu'à des jeux 2d j'entendais que dans la
bouche de mon père il genre je vais te
montrer j'ai d'esquinter vite et ce
quinté j'étais ce quinté et voilà choisi
ce quinté parce que moi j'avais que d2
d3 une catastrophe ma mère elle en
pouvait plus à proposer leurs effets je
leur ai fait je les ai faits belge en
effet pas fait oui oui sophy non j'avais
un aquarium il ya quelques temps et les
encres avait mis le chat dans l'aquarium
quand même non non ça va c'est quand il
a quand même j'espère le shah abbas le
chat s'appelle souvent de chez rip le
chat rip le chat mais allez on y va on
va prendre une position toutes les mères
le savent quand elles ne sont pas à la
maison le père et le fils font n'importe
quoi voilà brasser ses bons qu'à
regarder
hahaha
ah ah ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celle là je la dore prendre je te lis
ces rencontres officielles cela je
l'adorent hier dans le sens du rythme on
avait échappé bulldogs
et bien aujourd'hui on a retrouvé mini
cheb mami regarde et franchement il a le
choix gh et il a le choix d'outils a eu
trois mois il fait un prénom on voit
qu'il a il a de soi qu'il est frais il
et il est bien il est bien comme il va
s'appeler ton fils bougera alors
j'hésite encore je voulais dit cyril on
a une préférence pour les nommer bon ses
nombreux fils dont je pourrai pas courir
vers dommage et je pense que comme de
comme votre père s'appelle anges et que
dans la vie tout tous les garçons
s'appellent anges
je crois que je crois j'espère l'appeler
angelo si mahmoud abbas a frappé sa
façon des rares papa ça fera plaisir
m'ont pas draguer un bourreau d'enfants
toiletter cogneur angeleo c'est très
beau ça fait beau gosse franchement des
blues ont retourné à l'école des fans en
21e position avec un petit qui explique
pourquoi son parrain n'est pas là et je
vous dire après l'explication on
comprend mieux la parra il peut pas
venir y ait un contrôle fiscal
la voilà la situation voilà benjamins
ils paraissent aller prévu cet extrait
20 fois mais il est toujours aussi bon
c'est les deux gamines les plus keira de
monaco celle là voilà ça c'est c'est
notre qui font la vue enfin bon on était
obligé de le revoir garde
vous confronter à des expériences vous
aimeriez pas que papa de sache où maman
lesage est ce qu'il ya des dérapages
comme toutes les adolescentes
alors parfois on fait des choses avec
nos amis comme disons des bêtises à
lorsque vous êtes qu'est ce que vous
appelez des bêtises alors moi je m'en
souviens qu'à monaco on a deux amis qui
sont quand même très proches de nos est
alors une force étaient cachés derrière
des arbres à chaque fois qu'il ait des
gens qui passent et on faisait bouverat
lors séparent mais je suis fille c'est
magique mathieu c'est pas magnifique les
deux là hélas à celle attendue de
géraldine ça mais c'est vrai c'est la
pub avantageuse que j'ai fait c'était
bourg en 10ème position on sait que les
bébés adore goûter à tous c'est normal
mais quand il goûte pour la première
fois du coca ou du cola ou du pin cola
ou du pepsi-cola regardent ils
s'indignent ans
[Musique]
j'ai réagi comme ça avec la gamine mais
même aujourd'hui je ne supporte pas le
pétillant ça me fait drôle de sensation
je ne suis professeur d'eps et diabolo
saura comme ça vous le saurez
maxime kahn et ne supporte pas le
titille on voit la paille consignes
capitale
moi je le note dans un coin de ma tête
j'ai vite arrêté à venir oui j'ai trouvé
un bébé qui arrive à avoir peur et être
une mort de rire quand sa mère se mouche
imagine si ces enfants voyez gilles
verdez se moucher
[Musique]
c'est mignon ce soir on vous fait avec
ce top 30 des enfants franchement je
fais un kiff ça nous détend on arrive en
17e position
et là c'est un gamin il est calme
pendant que les parents font n'importe
quoi
sas ambiance comme on peut pendant le
confinement et oui il reste tranquille
il est zen regarde je suis très très fan
de suis très très fade ce qu'on voit là
en ce moment on fait des trucs de ouf et
ça fait du bien de voir ça at il dit
hier on vous a montré un enfant qui
avait peur du p d'une chèvre et bien
aujourd'hui regardez celui là il a peur
de son propre pays
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça a fait rire bal demain il se dit
cependant peur de son propre pays dans
des traitements forestière il faut
détruire non mais bien sûr jour apple a
bien sûr barack obama donné bon exemple
ou en 15e position va retrouver mon ami
michel boujenah on l'espère à un bon
rétablissement à bichat je crois qu'il
va mieux et on lui fait de gros bisous
en plus d'être drôle c'est un beau gosse
michel bull franchement il a toujours
été et moi moi ma soeur était folle de
michel boujenah je vous le dis alors il
est beau sauf pour cette gamine qui lui
a mis la misère regardez c'est la
quinzième position
et toi que tu aimes bien les garçons non
je n'aime pas pourquoi tu les aimes pas
tâche qui semble être
ils sont tous les garçons oui mais est
un appareil qui est gentil et yvan ils
sont peut-être de ne pas gentils ils
sont bêtes mais parfois ils sont beaux
moi par exemple 5 orties
je suis un garçon moi oui donc je suis
bête
oui je suis pas gentil et je suis moche
que l'anti vont continuer ça fait une
bio elle n'a pas cassé et michel il
était exceptionnel cette émission qu'il
avait fait et il était très très bon
dans cet exercice michel boujenah les
yeux des enfants posséder c'est pas que
dans les films dans les vidéos de
famille aussi regardez celle là est
complètement folle c'est un enfant qui
est possédée posséder 14e position
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est magique ça s'écrit jeunesse est en
14e position elle est exceptionnelle si
y'a pas toi qui lis ça fait du bien de
voir des vidéos comme ça ça nous change
les idées et on va rentrer alors en 13e
position rien de plus beau qu'une
demande en mariage c'est beau les
demandes en mariage un casting on sait
quand vous avez fait votre demande à
aurore vous a gelé fait dans un avion
non alors martiaux ibad dans l'avion je
les demande est un jeu les demander en
mariage c'était très bon été au dessus
de l'atlantique sur mac parce qu'on m'a
dit on ne pouvait pas se marier un ouais
mais bon c'est c'est pas mal et comme ça
ça permet à près de célébrer cette
demande dans l'avion bah bravo veux pas
savoir on veut pas en savoir plus c'est
vrai qu'une demande en mariage c'est
toujours très beau sauf quand un enfant
est là et qui décide de flinguer la
demande en mariage c'est ce qui est
arrivé en troisième position regarder
[Musique]
[Rires]
si je suis fan
je suis fan de 7 aujourd'hui pas de cet
enfant il est complètement ou viola d'or
à leur douzième position alors c'est une
vidéo sachez que ces cas kubecki prépare
l'émission et moi il l'a trouvée dans le
lin stade de kelly pédophilie
apparemment c'est une petite fille joue
avec un tuyau d'arrosage et voilà
regarder ce qui va lui arriver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pied gauche qui louent les enfants c'est
que les enfants au début ils se rendent
pas compte des bip et un moment tu
sentes sa part en cacahuète tu te dis
bah c'est pas bien pris et puis l'enfant
après dans sa tête ce tu sais pas ce qui
se passe ivry et commence à pleurer là
tu te dis pourquoi j'ai fait ça pourquoi
j'ai fait ça les têtes de bébé elles
sont toujours folle en général ils font
des têtes qu'on n'arrive plus à faire
après quand on est adulte ayant un père
qui a décidé de tout les refaire
regardez ça c'est énorme
[Musique]
il y en a eu
il est très fort le bébé y en a une que
j'adore parce qu'on rentre dans le top
10 xala je l'avais montré dans tpm pl
m'avez tué de rire c'est une mère qui
gueulent contre son fils au ski parce
qu'elle s'est pris de la neige
celle là je vous la dore et la voix elle
a la voix de toutes les mères domeo
regarder
[Musique]
roberge c'est bien il est super pour
l'appareil photo mh génial merci
il est foutu ces paravents un quinté
brown pas d'étonner tout naturellement l
exceptionnel cela allez on va rentrer en
deuxième position en ce moment il ya une
vidéo qui buzz partout ses deux parents
qui font un tour de magie à leurs
enfants qui comme un malade regarde
[Musique]
avait vu salage malajila l'adorent elle
fait le buzz en ce moment en huitième
position va pas se mentir il n'y a rien
de pire que de faire un live sur un
stade et il ya quelqu'un qui vient tout
faire qui veut tout faire pour te faire
foirer ton truc
regardez ce que fait ce petit frère à sa
soeur lui aussi je le kiffe voilà
j'aurais pu faire
[Musique]
mungo
les maisons
[Musique]
monde
la paix
[Musique]
je l'adorais pro bowl de la dore lui les
vaches à lait en septième position il ya
quelques jours via une vidéo qui a
cartonné sur les réseaux c'est des
parents qui ont font croire à leur
enfant que l'école reprend malgré le
confinement alors ça c'est hyper bien
fait regardez ils ont tout mis en scène
et les enfants ils sont au bout de leur
grand soleil attendu sur toute la france
aujourd'hui vous aurez 13 degrés à paris
15 à lyon il sera vain de derrière
marseille à l'homme de l'actualité ce
mec disait fin du congé mans pour les
enfants de la maternelle au lycée les
élèves vont reprendre dès demain le
chemin de l'école le corps navire et
c'est désormais derrière nous pour
attraper les trois semaines de
confinement les enfants vont devoir
aller en classe très très tôt le matin
et de repartir qu'à la nuit tombée ils
pourraient manger une seule fois par
jour si leurs parents estiment qu'ils
l'ont mérité
si les leçons n'ont pas été apprises
comme il le faut leur mère pourra les
obliger à dormir dehors
les ministres de l'éducation aux gens
les chèques bancaires a fait savoir
qu'il ne dirait pas de grandes vacances
cet été pour rattraper le retard
en revanche les parents justement qui
seraient des stickers et âme pour leurs
enfants et ce n'était pas une mince en
fait présent on du côté des maqueux voir
partir en voyage gratuitement en
amoureux les dents qu'il souhaite si
vous êtes concerné que vous avez des
enfants en bas âge les nous les rendrons
le relais certaines sont poussés vers
que d'autres aides seront choisis en
fonction de la gentillesse des enfants
c'est tout nouveau pour trouver la
première chez les truies
on évolue de mer de poisson d'avril
c'est au tour il va pas très bien
elles sont assez exceptionnelles à ce
qu'ils ont fait franchement très très
fort jean charles rielle scène
ouais ouais il un fichier ou jean michel
mr this way avait vécu durant limpide de
presse que non je crois qu'il en a un
petit aussi regarder
[Musique]
c'est belgique sont disponibles à les
buts de mes vidéos préférées vous vous
souvenez c'est baptiste baptiste il
s'était créé un koh-lanta en allumant un
saut dans sa chambre pour moi on l'a
placé numéro 4 cd vidéo qui m'a fait le
plus rire vraiment de ces dernières
années regarde la gueule du monde
tocoiste était temps oui dépêche toi à
10 est en train de faire je voulais un
truc dans sa gens aiment tant
mais savamment 28e qu'est ce que tu fais
mais c'est un fait non non non parets à
baptiste n'était pas net non monsieur et
demain matin comment tu vas te lever
mais je me suis mis la pression
si j'ai un prénom t'as fumé meurs je
taperai quelque chose j'ai repris
regarde le parquet dans l'état qui
veille à ce que l'un d'eux ici et il
vole il va être dans quel état je veux
les nuits nickel ouais t'as raison c'est
feu juste sous du couple portable
soubelet ton portable temps direct sur
facebook nu